firing a gunner calling the police
well because not everyone has a gun I
guess you still feel everyone's got a
cell phone but
I think that's some more convenience so
throughout history like you know you go
back 2 000 years ago they didn't really
have police like that yeah they didn't
have phones the cool police and they
didn't have
um guns so in those times we didn't
expect it for the man to take care of
his wife take care of his children take
care of his family yeah plus right it
was something we've been conditioned to
do I think and it's been passed on
throughout all generations even now when
people were saying that they don't want
toxic men is it outdated in 2022 I don't
think it's necessarily outdated because
I would want to be able to I would think
that I'd want to protect as a man I'd
want to protect my family and you know
any man who doesn't speak for you and
your wife's Gonna Leave You at some
point but you know I I think it just
goes back to how
um reality doesn't adhere to social
norms this it doesn't necessarily adhere
to um social Norm so you might say that
as a woman you know you're equal to me
and you know you're just as capable in
things as me but then let's be honest
there's biological differences I might
be more calm within that situation than
you you would be because your hormones
are different to mine and so it makes
more sense for me to you know be to
protector and be the one trying to
opens up what about you
ask the question again why are men
expected to be protectors when women are
just as capable of firing a gun or
calling the police
foreign
I I don't know why men are expected I
guess because it's it's just a thing
that
is innate in them to be protected but
like you said women are capable of doing
that but a lot of women
a lot of women don't want to and they
assume the man's going to do it anyways
so
they don't
they just don't
if that answers the question
okay go ahead what do you guys think
[Music]
uh well
at the end of at the end of the day it's
whatever is the best option that keeps
everybody safe so I think that's you
know that's what you go with
if
my ladies in the home you know I'm gonna
be like if someone breaks in do this
you know I'm saying if if
she's the one if she's gonna be by
herself that's what I would that's how I
would listen someone could break in if
you're worried this is what you do this
is the plan stick with that until
authorities get here whatever until I
get here you know what I'm saying so
yeah I just think like roles in
relationships are important so I feel
like even though like me as a woman I
can protect myself technically
um but at the same time I feel like if I
always had to be this woman oh I'm
protecting myself it I would kind of
just lose my femininity so I feel like
that is something that
for whatever reason it's been more
assigned to to men it's more of a
masculine trait and I feel like that's
something that's missing in our society
like men are no longer masculine and so
I don't think it's helpful for us to
take away things that make them more
masculine and things that make women
more feminine okay
I guess it's the difference between
capable of and should
I think the whole feminist argument as a
whole
is about proving that women are capable
of doing something that men can do
question is should they
should women be the lead in the
household should women be the
Breadwinners should women be the
protectors are they capable of it yeah
that woman's absolutely capable of
pulling that trigger
but in that household
with a man there should she she's by
herself absolutely I want I'm gonna take
my daughter to California and I'm going
to take her to a gun range someday I
want to teach her how to shoot a gun
when she's here I'm going to teach her
to respect the laws but she's going to
be able to
however do I want her to be in a
position to where she has to make that
choice no I want her to have a happy
family and a man that's going to protect
her
so she never has to make that decision
so I guess it I mean I don't know if it
properly answers your question but I I
think it's it's really a question of you
know feminism has
made women think
that because they are capable of doing
something that they should do you think
most women want to no
no I think they want to be protected and
they've been told that they should be
the protector which is against their
nature
yeah I agree I think they just keep
Society keeps telling them like you
should not you should be capable you
should be any you should be capable you
should be able to protect yourself but
it's gonna turn you off if something
happens someone brings it to your house
and your man doesn't protect you you
keep hearing like oh I want a feminine
man you know someone who's
in touch with the feminine side and all
that but I don't think so when that
happens you want what it's called a
toxic man these days some toxic
masculine to whatever you want to call
it
um yeah I think it would turn you off if
if that was the case but you should be
able to protect yourself can I just say
that if any woman that talks about toxic
masculinity or men attraction men of
this men are that if you think I'll
protect you when there's something's
going on yeah
are you saying that you wouldn't have
protected the whales why would I why
would you get did you get a t-shirt by
the way save the world it's coming soon
let's go and see Dory
on your channel I will not
in the show before
but because I one of my only fans I get
a lot of what they call themselves
feminists and they're like oh I like
being controlling whatever but because
though it's a fantasy they would tell me
like I'm a feminist I support women's
prize blah blah blah
but in the fantasy that they asked me
for like voice notes and whatever they
always want to be dominated that goes
out the window when they need to you
know get off it's true sure yeah I think
I've said this before on the show but
there is a Reddit thread of girls being
turned on by the handmaid's tale yeah I
started watching it after you yeah and
we're they're literally it's a show
where basically the world is infertile
except for a couple like like there's a
small minority of women that are still
fertile and they basically sell those
women to like Rich
families and the dude they'll be like
held down and engraved once a month
doing their Peak ovulation so that's why
whenever there's a abortion law that's
passed everyone's like we're going to
the handmaid's tale
and uh yeah and so there was a whole
Reddit thread where they're talking
about how turned on they were and women
and women are the most the ones that
watch it
I mean you feel you have to like a
little bit if you're watching you know
even um I don't know if you remember
that film came out during cover like 365
days or something yeah it's so cringe Oh
my days there was a zombie girl I don't
know you like me I haven't seen that
there's this one clip of this guy he's
like this um Italian pizza Italian like
Mafia sort of person right and um the
ladies in the shower and he grabs her by
her throat and all these obviously
obviously that would be seen if any man
did that in real life that would be seen